bonjour benoît martin merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation tôt ce matin
sur rtl france toutes les centrales
syndicales y compris la cftc qui
s'étaient abstenus à la fois précédente
ont d'ores et déjà prévu de nouveaux
recours quels sont ils
où écouter nos juristes sont
effectivement en relation les uns avec
les autres andy goode et des cinq
confédérations syndicales et donc ça
sera au camp les conseils d'état on
examinait voilà leur cours le plus
judicieux c'est lui qui a le plus de
chances d'aboutir mais en tout cas cela
fait déjà plus d'un an que cette réforme
a été
retardée empêcher et cetera il ya déjà
eu plusieurs recours auprès du conseil
d'état et ce n'est pas fini ça reste
murray semble profondément injuste
jusqu'à 40 % des allocataires chômage
vont qui vont voir effectivement une
baisse de leur allocation chômage est
décidément ce 1er octobre est un jour
très sombre la hausse des prix d'énergie
et l'application
chômage pour parler de réforme injuste
il s'agit d'une réforme phare du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro et
président avait dit le 12 juillet je
cite en france on doit toujours bien
mieux gagner sa vie en travaillant qu'en
restant chez soi ce qui n'est
actuellement pas toujours le cas ne
faut-il pas comme l'insinuent le
président s'attaquait au sujet tabou dit
de l'assistanat
n'ont écouté le président de la
république raconter des craques en
vérité alors certes il ya un certain
nombre d'emplois non pourvus en cela
existe mais il faut savoir quand même
qu'il y as 16 fois plus de demandeurs
d'emploi que d'emploi non pourvues
inspire qu'il n'y a pas une pénurie de
main d'oeuvre quand vous demandez par
choix mais il ya une pénurie d'emplois
et c'est bien ça la question
donc après on peut toujours en parler
voilà que les gens veulent pas
travailler que les gens scandent 7,5 à
la restauration recherche beaucoup
l'hôtellerie oui à vous parler d'un
métier en tension je ne vais pas nier
que ce métier en tension existe je vous
dis qu'il ya seize fois plus de
demandeurs d'emploi que de ce qu'on dira
que d'emplois non pourvus dans les
métiers en tension donc savoir la mesure
des choses il faut voir qu'on est google
est bien en présence d'un chômage de
masse et pas seulement les 3 millions
qui seront catégorie 1 1 chez les
demandeurs d'emploi mais également
toutes les catégories de demandeurs
d'emploi ce qui fait 6 millions en tout
plus sur lui qui vont un peu disparu de
la circulation
ils sont au rsa etc ou dans la rue puis
simplement cela fait des millions s'est
lâché plus d'un quart du monde du
travail qui est dans une grande
précarité aujourd'hui le conseil d'état
avait suspendu le durcissement du calcul
des indemnisations raison des
incertitudes économiques liées à la
crise sanitaire cet été c'est les
voyants sont au vert maintenant comment
comptez vous convaincre cette fois le
conseil d'état
alors les voyants sont au vert moi je
demande à voir c'est à dire que entre
2019 et 2000 et 2020 donc le pib a
baissé de 2 9%
cette année il augmente de 6%
semble-t-il donc on est toujours à moi 3
par rapport il ya deux ans donc on n'a
toujours pas retrouvé à une activité un
rythme de croisière tel qu'il était il
ya deux ans alors déjà ça c'est le
premier quoi et qu'y deuxième point des
côtes et voilà les les salaires sont bas
il ya beaucoup de chômeurs voilà il faut
nous augmenter les salaires il faut
embaucher massivement il ya tant de
choses à faire c'est pas le travail qui
manque ainsi c'est l'emploi ainsi
récemment il ya eu les premières le
mouvement des aides à domicile il a
également déjà mobilisés dans l'hôpital
public dans les ehpad parcours vous qui
demandez des emplois et donc pour
embaucher des gens aussi sur les
conditions de travail et les salaires
sur un peu plus attractives mais de
parler de mobilisation justement l'a vu
avec
nadège abderrazak il y à un appel à
manifester 5 octobre c'est mardi 5
octobre ça arrive vite à quel type de
mobilisation est ce que vous vous
attendez à ce que vous avez déjà des
retours sur une éventuelle participation
en termes de chiffres par exemple
oui alors il ya eu des appels à la grève
dans beaucoup de grandes entreprises et
administrations
il y aura 200 cortèges unitaires en
france et donc on s'attend à une reprise
de la mobilisation nous venons de vivre
quand même dix huit mois compliqués en
de crise sanitaire ou notre vie
syndicale a été pas mal perturbé il ya
eu un mois de réunions sont des lieux de
travail etc donc on les a loupés relais
de dirt mobilisation sociale autour des
questions centrales de l'emploi des
salaires de la réduction du temps de
travail de la défense des services
publics et puis également de défense de
la sécurité sociale dans son ensemble
ils compris la branche vieillesse des
livres qu'est ce qui concerne les
retraites
le texte
craint écran jusque dans les agences un
pôle emploi on avait à côté de vous des
images en agence pôle emploi avec la
mise en place d'un camp sécurité face à
de possibles agressions contre les
agents bonne ou mauvaise décision de
pôle emploi est ce que ça ne risque pas
de rajouter de l'huile sur le feu de la
tension supplémentaire
mais c'est surtout le révélateur d'une
une violence sociale vécue par les
chômeurs par les demandeurs d'emploi par
les précaires effectivement ils vont
être en colère il ne faudrait pas qu'ils
se trompent de colère qui le cette
colère siro porte sur les salariés de
pôle emploi qui sont de simples
exécutants c'est pas lui qui décide et
des politiques mais effectivement en ile
de france plusieurs centaines de
dispositifs d'alarmé sont installées
dans les agences pôle emploi pour faire
face à cette colère tout à fait
prévisible dont il faudra vraiment que
dans des vents portants que le
gouvernement retire ça va
merci venant martin
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général de la cgt
paris